so
given this short life
we could think about jiu jitsu we can
think about any kind of pursuit
what do you think makes a great life
is it the highest
peak of achievement you know you think
about like an olympic gold medal
the highest level of performance or is
it
the longevity of performance of doing
many amazing things and doing it for a
long time
i think the latter is kind of what we
talk about
in at least american society you know we
want people to be healthy
balanced perform well for a long time
and then there's maybe like the
gladiator
ethic which is the highest peak is what
defines
you asked an initial question which what
makes a great life
but then pointed towards two options
one of longevity versus are there a
degree of difficulty there's got to be a
lot more than that surely
i mean think about first of all we have
to understand from the start
there's never going to be an agreed-upon
set of criteria for this
is a great life from all perspective uh
if you look from
the perspective of say machiavelli then
stalin lived a great life
he was highly successful at what he did
he started from nothing
so the degree of difficulty and what he
did was extraordinarily high
he had massive impact upon world history
he oversaw the defeat of almost all of
his major enemies
he lived to old age and died of natural
causes
so from machiavelli's point of view he
had a great life
if you ask the ukrainian farmer in the
1930s whether he lived a great life you
get a very different answer
um so everything's going to come from
what perspective
you you begin with this you're going to
look out at the world with a given point
of view and you're going to make your
judgments was this a great life or was
this a terrible life
um going back to your point you were
actually
i think focusing the question on on more
in terms of uh great single performances
versus longevity performances yes
um presumably this isn't really a
question about
uh what makes a great life then because
there's so much more than
that to a great life i don't know i'm
going to push back on that so
i think their parallels are very much
closer than you're making them seem
i think it's let's compare stalin stalin
is an example
of somebody who held power considered by
many to be one of the most powerful men
ever he held power for 30 years
so that's what i'm referring to
longevity and then there's a few people
i have to i wish my knowledge of history
was better
but people who fought a few great
battles
and they did not maintain power but
that's this
contrast say for example alexander the
great yes who
died at 33 um from probably unnatural
causes
um uh had around
four to five truly defining battles
in his life which uh
responsible for the for the lion's share
of of his achievements
and burned very bright but didn't burn
long
um stalin on the other hand started from
nothing and quietly methodically worked
his way
through the revolutionary phase and uh
gained increasing amounts of power
and as he said um went all the way to
the end of her
uh of his career um yeah there's there's
definitely something to be said for
for longevity um
but as to which one is greater than the
other you can't
give a a definition
or um a set of criteria which will
definitively say
this is better than that but when you
look ultimately we look at alexander as
great but in a different way and we look
at stalin
you know i didn't think many people
would say sam was a great person but
from the monkey violent point of view
uh he would say he was uh
great also but when you think about
beautiful creations
done by human beings in the space of
say martial arts in the space of sport
what inspires you the peak of
performance i i
see where you're coming from like it's a
great question um for me it always comes
down to
degree of difficulty but things are
difficult in different ways
okay um a single flawless
performance in youth is still
that wins a gold medal let's say for
example um
uh nadia komenichi won the olympic gold
medal in gymnastics the first person
ever to get a perfect score
um if she had disappeared after that we
would still remember that as
an incredible moment and the degree of
difficulty to
to get a perfect score in olympic
gymnastics is
just off the charts um and contrast that
with someone who went to
four olympics and got four silver medals
i mean they're both incredible
achievements
they're just different the the
attributes that lead to longevity
um typically tend to conflict with the
attributes that bring a powerful single
performance
one is all about focus on on a
particular event the other is
on spreading your resources over time
both that present tremendous
difficulties
there's no need to say one is better
than the other
you